Megan Markel once revealed her wedding
dress style
[Music]
the actress and Prince Harry announced
their engagement on Monday but the 36
year olds had her own ideas about the
perfect wedding dress long before the
proposal in the season 5 cold feet
episode of suits which aired in 2016
markle's character Rachel Zane donned a
stunning white gown and in an interview
with Glamour at the time she shared her
personal idea of bridal gown perfection
quote classic and simple is the name of
the game perhaps with a modern twist I
personally prefer wedding dresses that
are whimsical or subtly romantic as for
the celebrity wedding gown that gives
her all the I do feels quote Carolyn
Bessette Kennedy everything goals in
1996
Carolyn tied the knot to John F Kennedy
jr. wearing a $40,000 Narciso Rodriguez
slip dress but Harry shouldn't expect to
see his bride all dressed in white
before she walks down the aisle
Markel told the mag quote I'm very
superstitious I wouldn't say that it's
bad luck I would just say I prefer
sticking with traditions
[Music]